the movie Bubble Boy which I think is so  great you started with beetlejuice  absolutely I said oh my god this is  either a career-ender or the greatest  thing ever it was a greatest thing ever  no matter what you like Bubble Boy yeah  and when you how was it working with  Beetlejuice and also you worked with  Bigfoot the original big foot tall guy  yes all from our shall we I know we had  a crew down I know I know  it was great I have to say I mean I  didn't get to really touch anybody cuz I  was in a bubble the whole time right  good but it was good movie to be in a  bubble  yeah can I take a moment and just say  that it is actually truly an honor to be  on the show thank you thank you here I'm  really glad we got to meet and he  returned kind of like an unbelievable  thing to be here so great to have you